a village in rote Island Indonesia
prepares to Welcome Home a missing Sun
other Sadia gelatin is overcome with
emotion
two of her sons both fishermen were on
board a boat that sank when Cyclone ilsa
passed through
only one of them has returned
as badko's side gelatin arrives they are
tears of joy and relief
a mother thankful that one of her sons
is alive
I feel happy but also sad because two of
my sons left and only one came back my
other son was my hope he was the
backbone of the family it hurts so much
to lose him
eight other men on board the boat with
badko including his brother are still
missing
at midnight the wind suddenly picked up
it flipped the boat over I could still
see the other man I grabbed my brother's
arm and hung onto the boat but a log hit
me and we were separated
another powerful wave struck and he lost
his grip on the boat he spent two days
adrift at scene
I kept thinking of my child when I was
swimming at night I heard my son's voice
calling my name it gave me strength
he drifted to a small remote island off
Australia's northwest coast where
another vessel struck by the same
powerful Cyclone had washed ashore all
10 crew from that boat survived they
would spend the next six days without
food and water before being spotted by a
passing Australia border Force plane and
rescued
the captain on board that boat is
thankful to be alive
we were tired we had no food no water we
drank salt water some people almost gave
up hope because they were too tired
someone said another two days would have
been dead
there is Joy tinged with sadness as he
returns to his family
he says he can't help thinking of the
men who are still missing fishermen like
him who rely on the sea to make a living
still haunted by his experience he says
it will be a while before he returns to
Sea
Florence Louis Al Jazeera